on forest hill road in jackson
mississippi a story which seems to touch
on so many of this nation's challenges
the story of tommy and celeste a couple
in a city without safe water it's sad it
is so sad
and it's something need to be done we
cannot even flush the toilet or nothing
it is so
bad
yesterday there was none today a little
but they can't drink it tomorrow who
knows
we could boil the water take a bath but
we can't take a bath in the water that
they have coming here
we can't take a bath in it so hang on so
hang on you haven't taken a bath without
boiling the water
since 2019.
it's a story about shoddy infrastructure
and chronic mismanagement yes
and made worse by storm damage but they
feel it's about much more than that this
is mostly the black area so we we only
have this problem anywhere you go they
have water
and good pressure with this area you
don't because they're mostly black
so i think they must be
uh talking this month or doing something
with this money
they had the money one time but now they
don't have the money
to me that just let you know they don't
care
about the black folk in my opinion
because in this area right here we've
been having this problem here for a long
time
here it's about improvisation to survive
here's where we have to catch the rain
water
to fill this tub up with for the fresher
toilet we don't really have to live like
this
it's like we're going back like in the
slave days
it's very very frustrating i'm tired
and uh we got to go
we should be living better than this
it's it's really sad down here in
mississippi is really sad
people down here need help bad
it's so sad here
i'm so sorry
it's okay
every day now they must drive to a water
distribution center the national guard
is on hand to help here
a signal that the immediate challenges
are now being addressed
but for this legacy of failure well
state and city officials blame each
other
and no one can tell tommy celeste and
the people of jackson when their water
will be safe
mark stone sky news in mississippi